>> Laura: WE RAISE THIS ISSUE
ON THE SHOW LAST WEEK, SHOULD
UNIVERSITIES BE DEFUNDED.
JOINING ME NOW, SOMEONE WHO’S
PICKED UP THE PART, CHARLIE, YOU
SAID IT’S SOMETHING DIVESTING
YOU.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT A
QUESTION MARK >> IT’S A PROGRAM
DONORS TO DECOMMENCE THEIR COMMI
COMMITTING TO THE DOWNFALL OF
AMERICA.
I’M PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THAT
TONIGHT THAT $7 MILLION FROM A
HANDFUL OF DAUGHTERS DECOMMITTED
FROM UNIVERSITIES SUCH AS
HARVARD AND BAYLOR UNIVERSITY
BECAUSE OF THEIR RESISTANCE TO
EMBRACE FREE-SPEECH POLICIES AND
IDEAS THAT ARE ABODES OF THE
BETTERMENT OF AMERICA.
LOOK, LAURA, DIVESTMENT IS A
TACTIC USED BY THE RADICAL LEFT
FOR DECADES.
IF WE AS CONSERVATIVES DON’T
LIKE BOYCOTTS AND ENGAGING IN
DIVESTMENT HOWEVER, WHY WOULD
YOU VOLUNTARILY CONTRIBUTE TO
THE UNIVERSITIES IF YOU WANT A
STABLE AND DECENT COUNTRY?
>> Laura: WHY DO YOU WANT TO
GIVE TO SOMEBODY WHO HATES YOU.
THAT HATES WHATEVER TRANSITIONAL
AMERICA OR WHATEVER YOU CALL IT
IN PRECOVERED AMERICA.
IF YOU WANT TO CHANGE THAT AND
YOU HATED IT, YOU SUPPORT PEOPLE
WHO TEAR DOWN STATUES OR THROW
PAINT AT THE VIRGIN MARY STATUE
SO WHY DO YOU WANT TO GIVE INTO
THAT?
THEY WANT FREE SPEECH AND YOU
KNOW COME DOWN ON THE SIDE OF
THE LOOTING AND BURNING OF
AMERICA, IT’S FINE TO GIVE MONEY
BUT OTHERWISE WHY ARE YOU PAYING
$50,000 A YEAR INTUITION TO
CHARLIE CHARLIE FOR ONLINE
CLASSES?
IS A TOP UNIVERSITY AND THAT IS
LOW.
IF 50,000 IS LOW FOR TUITION AS
YOU NOW.
>> COLLEGES ARE EXPOSING HOW
MUCH THEY’VE BEEN RIPPING OFF
STUDENTS AND NOW THEY’RE SAYING
BUDGET ON TUITION AND HARVARD IS
DETERRING OVER $50,000 A YEAR
FOR JUST A ZOOM CALL?
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS AND NOT TO
MENTION YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE
STUDENTS WHO PERPETUALLY STUDY
THINGS THAT DON’T MATTER AND
THEY DON’T HAVE THE FIND JOBS
THAT DON’T EXIST.
I DON’T GET ANY PRICE ADJUSTMENT
FROM THE UNIVERSITY AND THE
BROADER POINT IS THAT ALUMNI AND
DONORS ARE WONDERING WHAT WE CAN
DO.
STOCK AND SHEPHERDING YOUR
HARD-EARNED DOLLARS TO THE POWER
CENTERS OF THE LEFT THAT ARE
ORGANIZING AND GIVE CREDIBILITY
TO THE RADICAL THINKING AND THE
INTELLIGENCE OUT THERE AND
LIBERTY OF UNIVERSITY BEING ONE
THEM.
>> Laura: I LIKE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO AND LIKE NOTRE DAME,
OTHER SCHOOLS BUT THEY ARE GOOD